hi my name is Jen Arie and today I'd
like to talk about why you should add
logging to your code and hopefully how
to make it more
helpful we have uh in production shiny
apps Plum apis and our markdowns I work
in the insurance industry and so for
example we have a plumber API that helps
price insurance policies so something
goes wrong we need to know about it
right away so when we get something like
this and our markdown that run hourly it
gets a little Annoying what is this
error how do we fix it it' be nice to
have some helpful hints to help you
understand what happened and maybe uh
some convenient ways of getting notified
um when this error
happens so when you're going through
your code it's kind of like walking in a
dark forest and you're not sure exactly
where you're going but by including some
type of logging you can have these Trail
markers that are on trees so you have
some sense of idea of where you're going
and how to troubleshoot your code so to
demonstrate I have the simple plumber
API we're just going to divide some
numbers we have a as a numerator and B
as a denominator and then for example we
do 100 by 4 we're going to get 25 as a
result okay so to add our first TR
marker we're going to use the log 4 R
here as a demonstration purpose we're
going to define the loger object and
then below we have an informational
message says attempting to divide a by B
so now when we run through this example
again we're going to see in our console
info attempting to by 100 by4 so that's
kind of
useful so we're going to add a second sh
marker here what if we want to know when
somebody does not include an input we
want to be notified of that so we're
going to include a warning message here
so when there's no inputs in the
numerator or denominator your the user
is going to receive back or must Supply
numerator or denominator and in our
console we're going to see this warning
message with the same message so that's
interesting but only you are going to
see this message no one else that you
care about is going to see this and be
notified when this error happens so we
need to go beyond these Trail markers on
trees and you have some type of
satellite Communicator capability to let
people know when these types of things
happen when I go hiking by myself I have
a satellite communication device like
this to let my wife know where and when
I'm at at all times so she can feel uh
at ease when I'm doing things like
this so um if you want to add side
Communicator capability to your logging
there's a bunch of sources um available
Azure Amazon web services and Google
Cloud all have their own type of logging
service available where you can send
your OS log file directly or interact
with a logging system with an
API so to add sight communic
communication ability to our example
we're Jo we're just going to uh modify
the logger uh and add a sis log appender
we're going to call it division
calculator API what's CIS log well sis
log is on a Linux system the systems
primary logging file you see a bunch of
CIS log files here and then in that CIS
log you're going to see a bunch of
random stuff in there that you don't
really care about but you're also going
to see your output for in this case
division calculator API mus Supply
numerator and denominator so now there's
a source file that's being written to so
what we have on organization we have our
plumber shiny applications and it's all
on hosted on a posit connect instance on
our virch machine running Linux and then
all that is writing to our CIS log file
and we have it integrated with Azure
monitor so all those CIS log files get
uploaded to the cloud and now when you
go to web browser you can conveniently
see in your CIS log table where process
name equals division calculator API so
now you see all those messages and if
you wanted to you can filter it out so
you don't see the informational messages
you just see the
warnings and you can even set up alerts
so you know when those things happen and
get notified by email or if you really
want to by text
messages maybe not everyone wants to do
that um but I hope from this talk you
can see that when you have your code
it's kind of like walking in the dark
Forest you really don't know where you
are but by including loging uh you have
a better sense of where things could go
wrong and by using a cloud monitoring
solution it's like having a satellite
communication device to let people know
what's going on I'd love to talk more
about logging but you can use this QR
code in this link below to learn more
about it um and if any of these things
resonate with you let's chat thanks so
much